Vice President Mike Pence says the
president's State of the Union address
passed an inspiring vision of American
greatness he says the vice president
just spoke with CBS Evening News anchor
Jeff Glor in an interview you'll see
only on CBS this morning they talk first
about the partial government shutdown do
you think the shutdown was a mistake I
never think it's a mistake why to stand
up for what you believe in
and I think what the American people
admire most about this president is he
says what he means and he means what he
says that in a very real sense he said
there's a crisis at our southern border
he said he was determined to get the
funding to build a wall and and secure
our border and he was willing to take a
stand to accomplish that now we we
agreed to reopen the government for
three weeks because after talking to
Democrat rank-and-file members of the
Senate and of the house we we were told
that they were willing to work with us
they were willing to fund a barrier at
our southern border and to address the
other priorities of the president laid
out in that common-sense approach we've
taken them at their word but the
American people saw this president is
absolutely determined to keep his word
to secure our border and end the crisis
of illegal immigration one line that
made news last nights in the State of
the Union was when the president said
quote if there's going to be peace and
legislation there cannot be war and
investigation is an oversight part of
the Legislature's job I mean you you
served in the house for more than a
decade I did I did
well a congressional oversight is a part
of the checks and balances of our system
but but isn't he saying that can't
happen well what the president referred
to last night was partisan
investigations and you know you've
spoken about the president you know his
feelings about about investigations on
Capitol Hill we don't object to
oversight that's the proper role of
committees in Congress but when it takes
on a partisan tent when it when it it
seems more intent on becoming a forum
for invective against the president and
against the administration the American
people expect better the American people
want to see the Congress addressing the
issues that the president laid out last
night I mean the president laid out a
positive agenda for a growing American
economy for a stronger military for an
America that's addressing the real
challenges that are facing American
families that's what the American people
want our Congress focused on Jeff Glor
joins us now from Washington Jeff hello
its nine days and Counting before we
find out what's gonna happen with the
shutdown did the vice president tell you
about the possibility of another one
yeah Gail I asked him I said can you
guarantee there will not be another
government shutdown and he said no I
can't guarantee that it is interesting
to see some of the language the
President and the Vice President used
both last night and this morning they
refer to this as as an urgent national
crisis but they're not saying it's a
national emergency right now we're not
saying they will declare a national
emergency I think both sides at this
point from our discussions with everyone
here yesterday are pointing to this
bipartisan committee on Friday and
hoping that some sort of potential
solution can emerge there that maybe
both sides can be happy with before we
hit this deadline on the 15th alright
Jeff thank you